[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today
Courtney's in Oklahoma City hey Courtney
what's
up hey Dave hey Jade how are you guys
doing better than we deserve well how
can we
help um so first of all Jade I'm a huge
fan I've seen your debt free scream
about a hundred times it's it's
fascinating to me awesome it's awesome
it is awesome I um I am I've been
married for 12 years um my husband and I
have three kids we have almost $100,000
in total debt and we're on baby step two
um and when we pay off these small cards
you know that's that's great that's a
great morale booster I would say it's
it's easy um instant satisfaction and we
have some bigger balances that are
coming up that I know are not going to
have that sat that instant
gratification um so what I'm asking is
how can I keep morale and encouragement
with my husband and I in between as we
come into these larger balances that we
know are going to take longer and
there's not going to be some instant
gratification there yeah what are what
are the biggest balances that you have
we have two $20,000 cards and one
$20,000 student loan debt okay that's
not as that's not as bad as I thought
you were going to say what's your
income uh we make collectively almost
995,000 a year and um at this point how
much are well like what's your margin
going to the debt snowball every month
we can maybe put an extra 150 he's
working two jobs I'm working jobs did
you say 150 what dollars no girl out of
95,000 yeah you shouldn't have told me
that that's that's not intense that's
not intense at all well no wonder you're
worried about these $220,000 balances
because that's going to take
forever yeah I think it's it's it helps
more when they're the smaller car
because the smaller cards get paid off
well it helps more because you're not
paying anything on them right you mean
you got a $150 card it works real good
pay 150 but it doesn't work real good
when you got 20,000 you got to put 2,000
not
150 so he's actually active duty
military he's an officer we've had about
almost our entire marriage in active
duty military okay and he's um he
actually did the green to Gold program
so that he could become an officer he
was enlisted that obviously comes with
more income okay um and he gets promoted
next week so that's a significant H
makes 95 now and you're only putting 150
why where's all your freaking money
going uh debt that I accumulated from my
parents that no you have you already
told us the debt okay yeah how much are
you paying on how much are you paying to
your
parents oh I'm not I that's they took
things out in my social security number
well why would you pay it that's called
fraud correct you're correct why would
you pay it you don't need to pay that
file a police report and tell the police
you know where the criminal
is I'm not kidding at all yeah right who
steals from their own kid that's a great
question what's the amount people that
go to jail that's who it is yeah what's
the amount of
that um it wasn't that wasn't very much
but there probably about 10,000 of that
okay so let's just stop a second let me
go back you you sidetracked me there
with that ridiculous story of your crazy
parents um the but the deal is still
this you got $95,000 coming in that is
not all going to $10,000 worth of debt
that your parents took out in your name
where the flip is all your money
going uh my car payments and other how
much is your car payment uh mine's $700
okay what's the other car payment his is
950 sell the stupid
cars today those are completely
asinine who has $1,800 worth of car
payments and calls worth of financial
trouble I mean you sell your cars do you
see how much quicker you would pay off
your debt if you had that extra $1,700
freed up $1,650 freed up you are car
poor have you got a Ford tattoo on your
forehead do they own
you you should get one they own you wow
and a Chevrolet tattoo on the other arm
or whatever it is oh my God
9700 we found your problem
goodness it is cars you guys got car
disease they sure do Austin we make sure
they
Geto amputate the Tahoe shoot woo this
is a Ramsey sh